MIHAI IONESCU: Hello.
Welcome to our special
edition office
hours on Google Checkout.
My name is Mihai Ionescu.
I'm a developer advocate
on Google Wallet.
And following our recent
announcement about Google
Checkout retirement, we wanted
to give developers and
merchants more information
about the process, more
details, and answer any
relevant questions.
With me today we have Justin
Lawyer, Senior Product Manager
on Google Wallet and Michael
Hogan, Payments Operation
Specialist on Wallet.
So let's get started.
First Justin will walk you
through the major things you
should know, and then
we'll answer
questions from the moderator.
So let's switch to
the slidedeck.
JUSTIN LAWYER: So we have a
quick presentation here to
help you understand what this
retirement means for you as a
Google Checkout merchant.
So the first things we want
everybody to understand is
there are three things.
First, you can still process
payments through Google
Checkout for the next
six months.
You'll be able to charge orders
until November 20.
The second thing we'd like you
to understand is that we've
partnered with best of breed
e-commerce solutions partners
to be able to help you with the
transition to help make
that a more seamless
experience for you.
The third thing that we want
to make sure that you
understand is that you can
contact us at any time during
this migration for questions
and to help answer any
questions that you have.
For the agenda today we first
wanted to clarify.
We've heard a number of
questions about what is Google
Wallet versus Google Checkout
and so we want to [INAUDIBLE].
And then December 20 is the
last day for merchants
initiate refunds for those
Checkout orders.
For the migration options
there are basically two
classes of options for
you as a merchant.
If you choose to use Google
Wallet Instant Buy, that is an
offering for you that offers an
optimized mobile solution.
And you will need to have
a separate payment
processor for you.
If you are using digital
goods you can
migrate to that offering.
If you would choose to use one
of our partners you can
migrate to Braintree for payment
processing or any
other processor that
you choose.
They're offering discounted
processing for you.
Shopify has discounted plans
if people would like hosted
storefront.
And FreshBooks is offering an
online invoicing solution for
anybody that needs invoicing.
For the next part of the agenda
there were a number of
questions about digital
goods merchants
using Google Checkout.
So first of all, we want to
basically clarify that sales
of digital goods are
largely unaffected.
Users of Google Play, Google
Web Store, the Offers
Marketplace, and the Google
Wallet for digital goods, the
only change that they will
really see is they will be
using the new Google Wallet
Merchant Center.
So that will basically be
fairly transparent.
For those merchants using Google
Play or other Google
properties that are also using
the Google Checkout
notifications and order report
APIs, they will need to
migrate to the replacement.
MIHAI IONESCU: Thank
you Justin.
So now let's get to the fun
part, answering questions from
the moderator.
I have the list in front of me
here and I'll go through the
question and then find someone
who knows the best answer.
So let's start with
the first one.
The first question is, didn't
Google migrate all Google
Checkout users to Google
Wallet in 2011?
So Justin, I think you
briefly covered
it, but can you elaborate?
JUSTIN LAWYER: So this is
a very good question.
We get asked this frequently,
actually.
And yes, in 2011 we migrated
all buyers on Google to a
single Google Wallet
unified experience.
So that way all buyers have the
exact same experience and
they knew what to expect
whenever they saw the pay with
Google button.
The merchant solutions, whether
that was Google Wallet
for digital goods or Checkout
or Google Play were distinct
and different for
each of those.
And so those were continuing
under their different names.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
Next question is about the
Google Checkout API, so I
think I'll take that one.
It's my area.
The question is, I have a Google
Checkout API which
gives me notifications to
unlock digital goods.
I made no changes to my code
when Checkout became Wallet.
It still works.
From my perspective, Wallet is
just a risk in Checkout.
So the question kind of relates
a little bit to what
Justin just talked about.
From the developer's description
here I take it
that he or she is using the
digital delivery option on
Google Checkout, which
is a nice API.
Unfortunately, that will
go away when we
retire Google Checkout.
The good news is there
is a replacement.
We have the Google Wallet for
digital goods API, which is
very nicely suited to deliver
digital content, digital goods
to your customers.
You will need to do a little
bit of programming on your
website because it sounds like
you're nicely integrated and
you're probably using some key
to unlock digital goods.
So the digital goods API, it's
a nice processing option for
you and with a little bit of
work on the website you should
be good to go and have
a nice replacement.
There are also alternatives
out there.
You can look at Braintree, which
has also a nice solution
for digital goods.
So keep sending us questions
if you have trouble.
But I think with just a few
days of work you should be
able to nicely switch
to the new solution.
OK, the next question.
What are the discounted
transactions
fees from Google partners?
I'll take this one.
So we announced a few days ago
that Checkout will be retired
and in that announcement we
also provided options for
existing merchants
and developers.
And out of those I want to
emphasize Braintree, which is
one of our partners, which is
offering very substantial
discounts, especially if you
have large volume sales.
Do we have it on the website?
Can we switch to the
Braintree website?
And the entry level rates
are 2.7% plus--
I think the Braintree
website--
MICHAEL HOGAN: $0.30.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yep.
The Braintree website we have
links from the Merchant Center
and we can go to each one of our
partners and sign up for
their special rates.
So Braintree has 2.7%
plus $0.30 that is
the entry level rate.
Then Shopify, which offer
entire hosted storage
solution, offers 20%
off of their plans.
Or if you're using invoice
primarily you may want to
consider FreshBooks, which
has a 60 day free trial.
So lots of options for you
depending on the specific
processing, platform, and
specific processing
needs that you have.
So to recap, go to the Merchant
Center and you'll
have all the information
there.
All right, next question.
I'll give it to someone else.
Is Google Wallet Instant Buy the
only other Google provided
option for receiving and
processing payments?
How costs will differ between
the two products?
So Michael, you're the
expert in this area.
Can you elaborate?
MICHAEL HOGAN: So we do have
another product, Google Offer
Digital Goods that's
exclusively for
digital goods merchants.
It's a web based solution and
we have actually pretty
competitive pricing.
So it's 5% per transaction
or 1.9% plus $0.30 per
transaction, whichever
is cheaper.
MIHAI IONESCU: Whichever
is better.
Yep.
MICHAEL HOGAN: I am glad you
brought up the question about
instant buy.
It's a great product but
certainly isn't a one to one
replacement for Google
Checkout.
Instant buy partners are
required to have their own
processing capabilities.
So for that reason it's not a
great fit for a lot of Google
Checkout merchants.
Also for that reason it's
a free service.
Any sort of fees associated
would be with their
proprietary credit
card processor.
And we just offer the
service for free.
MIHAI IONESCU: So there are
multiple options out there
from what you're telling me.
If you have digital goods you
can just switch to Google
Wallet for digital goods and
use our very competitive
pricing structure.
Or if you have a payment process
or if you plan to use
any payment processor Google
Wallet Instant
Buy is a good option.
It's free from Google and then
you will be charged whatever
your payment processor
charges you.
MICHAEL HOGAN: Absolutely.
MIHAI IONESCU: And you can use
Braintree, for example.
MICHAEL HOGAN: Yep.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
Thank you, Michael.
Let's move on.
Next question.
The question is, merchant
retailer of electronic
physical goods.
Will we be able to use Google
Wallet as a payment process in
place of Google Checkout?
So Michael, I think that's
also down your alley.
MICHAEL HOGAN: Happy to
take this question.
No.
The answer is that we no longer
offer a solution for
processing of physical goods
or accepting payments for
physical goods or services.
For that reason we've chosen
these three partners.
They're well regarded in the
payments industry and so if
payment processing needs to
be replaced, for example,
Braintree payments is
a great solution.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
But in particular this retailer
they could use Google
Instant Buy and then have their
own payment processor or
Braintree process
the payments.
MICHAEL HOGAN: So long as they
have a payment processor like
Braintree in place, then they're
encouraged to use
Instant Buy.
And we'll be able to
take Google Wallet.
MIHAI IONESCU: To clarify a
little bit for people who are
not familiar with how Google
Instant Buy works, customers
could use Google Wallet to
purchase your physical goods.
However, you as a merchant we
will not be processing the
payments for you.
Instead we will give you virtual
on time credit card
that you would need then
to charge with
your payment processor.
So it's very convenient because
you have access to our
large user base and all
the customers who are
using Google Wallet.
However, there's an extra step
which actually gives you more
flexibility.
You will be able to charge the
credit card directly with your
preferred payment processor and
then use the cast majority
of APIs available to do
additional post processing
that are available from your
payment processors.
MICHAEL HOGAN: I think it's good
to point out the benefit
here too is order processing
payouts.
Google is no longer involved
there which sort of makes
things a little bit simpler
for the merchant.
MIHAI IONESCU: So very
important point.
Thank you for clarifying.
All right, one more question
related to payment options.
The question is, as a provider
of e-learning taking courses
where Google Checkout is our
primary payment option, what
options do we have ones Google
Checkout ceases?
Our ability to receive payment
simply expires or do we move
to Google Wallet?
So from the question it sounds
like currently you are selling
digital content or digital goods
and you're using one of
the Google Checkout APIs.
Probably digital deliver API.
I think we addressed
this in a previous
question and in the slides.
The best solution for you is
to consider migrating to an
API that is specifically
designed for digital goods.
On the Google Wallet side we
have Google Wallet for digital
goods, which will offer you
similar capabilities and will
also the processing for you.
Alternatively, you can shop
around and there are quite a
few good solutions out there.
Again I'm pointing to Braintree,
which has a nice
digital goods solution.
So there are options for you but
you will have to move off
the Google Checkout API
in the six month time
frame we gave you.
OK, one additional question,
which is also API related so I
will take this one as well.
Which API provided by Google
proves best in the scenario
where the merchant needs
to provide facility for
subscription based statement
and also support modifying
subscriptions and give a
postback call with every
recurring billing?
Sounds like a very particular
and more complex
case you have here.
So we don't know exactly the
specifics of your business.
But talking generally about
subscriptions, we do have
options and we can also
recommend to you other
possible solutions.
So depending on the complexity
of your app and the platform
where you're selling the
subscriptions, you can have
Android in app billing, which
offers subscriptions.
You can charge directly
from within your
native Android app.
On the web we have Google for
Digital Goods which has a
subscription component.
And you can also switch
to that one.
And of course there
are third parties.
And we mentioned before,
Braintree has recurring
billing solution.
You can switch to that
one as well.
So again, look around and choose
the best API that fits
your particular case and the
complexity of your situation.
All right, are we
done with APIs?
OK, let's take a question
that's not API related.
What will happen to my merchant
ratings after the
Google shut down?
So I think Michael you're
the best to answer that.
MICHAEL HOGAN: Sure.
So Google ratings primarily
applies are
using Google Shopping.
And they have a life
of one year.
So as ratings stop they will
live out their, I guess,
lifespan for the rest of
the year and then will
begin to fall off.
We do have other ratings that
feed into that system.
Bizrate, Pricegrabber, and those
will continue to be fed
into the Google Shopping
system.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
So your ratings will be
available for one year and
then once Checkout is out
they will go away.
MICHAEL HOGAN: Yep.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
OK, another API and subscription
question, so
that'll be me.
The question is, how can
I maintain my customer
subscriptions after Google
Checkout is closed?
So if you're using the Google
Checkout subscription API that
API will go away
in six months.
So you will have to move off the
subscription, the Checkout
subscriptions API to another
platform, to other equivalent
subscription solution.
If you're selling digital goods
or services, we do have
the Google Wallet for Digital
Goods API, which is a good
replacement.
If you're doing this on mobile,
let's say Android
native apps, then we have
Google inn app billing.
Any other scenarios or
combinations of the two, you
can use both of them or you
can consider third parties
like Braintree.
So somehow a similar and a
repeat answer to a previous
question but the main point is
you will have to migrate your
existing customers to a new
subscription platform and
restart the subscriptions.
JUSTIN LAWYER: I might add that
if you have questions
about this, feel free to call
our number and we can help you
through that process.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes so make sure
you note down the contact
information.
I'll rewind the video
and it's--
JUSTIN LAWYER: It's also
in the help center.
MIHAI IONESCU: And it's also
Think you.
Thank you, Justin.
All right, one next question
is about the mobile
experience.
So the question is, last year
Google Checkout stopped
serving mobile optimized
pages.
What is the best way to have
a mobile optimized checkout
experience on my
mobile web app?
So the important thing to
note here is that it is
a mobile web app.
So Mike, I think you know
more about this.
MICHAEL HOGAN: So we built
Google Wallet Instant Buy to
be a beautiful experience
on mobile.
For that reason it's easing
check out both in app and on a
mobile site.
But again, can't emphasize this
point enough, merchants
must have ability to process
their own credit cards to be
eligible for this tool.
So if you're looking for mobile
and have that ability,
have a PCI compliant credit card
processor, then this is
definitely a solution for you.
MIHAI IONESCU: So, Instant Buy
it's a nice replacement that
works as well on both your
desktop and your mobile web.
And the experience
is seamless.
So if you have a web store
then you can have your
customers buy either in the
browser on the desktop or from
their mobile phone and the
experience will seamless.
MICHAEL HOGAN: Exactly.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
OK, one more for Mike.
It's an API related question
but you are the
best to answer it.
And the question is, when might
the Instant Buy API be
generally available even
just for Sandbox?
MICHAEL HOGAN: Sure.
So we're opening Sandbox to a
limited beta soon in the next
couple weeks.
As soon as we really have felt
that out and made sure we have
a great experience
for all users,
we'll open it up publicly.
And we'll make sure anyone who
fills out our interest form at
getinstantbuy.withgoogle.com
will be informed of all of
these steps as they
take place.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
So that's great news for
developers and people who want
to try Instant Buy.
Will have Sandbox
to play with.
And do we have--
so it's Get Instant Buy?
MICHAEL HOGAN:
Getinstantbuy.withgoogle.com.
MIHAI IONESCU: And there's
a sign up form.
Just go there.
JUSTIN LAWYER: So it's
a really easy url.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right,
questions keep coming.
All right, Mike, you're
on a roll so I'll
give this on to you.
So the question is, will there
be a new Merchant Center for
merchants using Google Wallet
for the digital goods API?
Is then is, will there be a way
to support cancellation of
subscriptions, refunds,
and charge backs?
MICHAEL HOGAN: And the
answer is yes.
We have great news
on this front.
So we've rolled out a
new merchant center.
It's actually for purely in app
merchants-- or excuse me,
for purely digital
goods merchants.
It's already being used.
We're rolling out to
Android right now.
And that includes
a subscription
orders details page.
So before you'd have to back
track all the way through the
Merchant Center to find the
original subscription in order
to cancel that order.
Now all of the subscription
information is housed on one
order details page so you can
see all of the charges made
through the months or years
and cancel it if
need be right away.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, I can vouch
for from a ease of use
point of view.
The new Merchant Center is
much better than the
equivalent Google Checkout
Merchant Center for
subscriptions.
MICHAEL HOGAN: Absolutely.
MIHAI IONESCU: It's so much
easier to see where the
subscription is coming, how to
cancel it, how to refund.
Yeah, so definitely
it's there.
If you're a digital goods API
user or merchant you already
have it and it's going to be
rolling out to Android
merchants as we speak.
MICHAEL HOGAN: Yep.
Absolutely.
MIHAI IONESCU: Next question.
API question, so
I will take it.
The question is,
will the entire
Checkout API be retired?
There are some Checkout APIs
in the level two, which is
order processing, that seems
useful for other Google Wallet
APIs that are blocking such
features such as cancellation
and notification call backs,
notification history queries,
so on and so forth.
And this is a very
good question
and a very good point.
And it clearly this developer
is using the level two APIs
which are complex APIs and is
looking to do post order
processing and some very
complex operations.
To answer the question,
the entire
Checkout API will go away.
So if you are using any of those
APIs you will need to
find a replacement depending on
the particular API you're
switching to.
The good news is that we will
be rolling out new APIs new
replacement for this before
Checkout completely retired.
So you will be able to
seamlessly transition to a
similar experience on your
server side and make your life
much easier.
JUSTIN LAWYER: In particular
Android Play developers,
there's one in the works
right now and it
will shortly be released.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
Great, so good news for
Android developers.
If you're using any of the
existing Checkout APIs you
will soon have a replacement.
All right, are we done
with API questions?
OK, one that's not
an API question.
As a nonprofit how can we
continue to accept donations
through Google Wallet.
Addressing.
JUSTIN LAWYER: So this
is a good question.
Google Checkout will
unfortunately be completely
turning off support of donations
after November 20.
So if you're either a 501(c)(3)
needing to do
donations or if you're a
political group needing to do
contributions that way
we suggest you
get a different processor.
Braintree actually
does support both
of those use cases.
If you like the buyers to be
able to use Google Wallet to
pay for that, you can use Google
Instant Buy and that
way we can provide the one time
use card and then you can
process it through Braintree
or any other processor that
you would like.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
OK, Justin, your turn.
Another question for you.
The question is about
the worldwide
availability of Checkout.
And it's will you offer
a new API for
Google Wallet worldwide?
Current Google Checkout API
cannot be used from most
countries other than
the US and UK.
JUSTIN LAWYER: Yes, this is
a very good question.
The answer kind of depends
on how you're
using Google for payments.
If you're selling digital goods
on Google, for instance,
through Google Play, we support
161 buyer countries,
so quite a few.
And we have 32 seller
countries.
If you're a Google Wallet for
digital goods merchant, we
have 18 seller countries, nine
different currencies, and also
161 buyer countries.
If you are using Google Instant
Buy, since that is a
limited beta at this point it
only supports US buyers and US
sellers and we're actively
looking at how do we roll that
out traditional countries
as the beta finished up.
MIHAI IONESCU: So I think the
point of your answer is that
using some of the new Google
APIs you actually have access
to more options and more buyers
and more currencies
that you would have
had in Checkout.
JUSTIN LAWYER: Yeah.
Google Checkout, for instance,
only supported two seller
countries, US and UK.
And if you are a digital
merchant switching to Google
Wallet for digital goods for
instance, that would be 18
seller countries.
So you'd be expanding your
footprint of where you can
actually sell.
MIHAI IONESCU: And Instant Buy
will gain more traction and
you'll have more options
there too.
OK, next question.
It's about Merchant Center.
The question is, will it be
possible with the new Wallet
Merchant Center to sell apps
on Google Play from more
countries that are not supported
by Google Checkout?
So related to the previous
question, I guess, but Mike
you know more about this.
MICHAEL HOGAN: Sure.
We're evaluating and expanding
to new countries all the time
but we don't have anything
to announce at this time.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
So you're still having the
18 countries and lots of
currencies and we're adding--
MICHAEL HOGAN: Additional
countries constantly.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
So we're getting close
to the end.
One more question and I
will take this one.
And the question is about the
Google Checkout store gadget.
What is the transition path for
users of Google Checkout
Store gadget?
So the Checkout Store gadget
offer the nice one stop
solution for merchants
with no or very
limited programming skills.
And it was very popular and used
by quite a few merchants.
Once Google Checkout is retired,
the best option for
such merchant will be Shopify,
which offers discounted plans
for, again, a one in all
hosted storefront.
So the transition and the
experience from a merchant
perspective and managing your
store should be similar.
So I encourage everyone who uses
the Checkout Store gadget
to have a look at Shopify.
All right, so with this
I think we got to
the end of the questions.
If there are questions that we
missed we'll try to address
them in further office
hour session.
Thank you, Justin, and thank
Michael for providing
additional details about the
Google retirement plan.
And please contact us with any
issues, any questions, and
we'll see you next time.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]